[Music]
to
start things off here i'm curious if you
could explain
what omoemua's wager is and and what
does it mean for humanity in our future
was the first interstellar object that
was spotted near earth
and by interstellar i mean an object
that came from outside the solar system
we knew that because it moved too fast
to be bound to the sun
it's just like finding an object in your
backyard
from the street and it saves you
the need to go to the street and find
out what's going on out there
uh in particular from my perspective it
allows us to
figure out if the street has neighbors
uh if we are the smartest kid on the
block
because this object looked unusual it
didn't look like
any rock that we have seen before in the
solar system
um it exhibited a very extreme
shape because it changed it the amount
of reflected sunlight by a factor of
tennis it was tumbling every eight hours
uh it also didn't have a cometary tail
there was no gas or dust around it
yet it showed an excess
push away from the sun and the only
possible interpretation that came to my
mind was a reflection of sunlight
and for that the object had to be very
thin sort of like a
sail but being pushed by sunlight rather
than
by the wind as you often find on a boat
and the nature doesn't make sales so in
a scientific paper we propose that maybe
it's
artificial in origin and since then in
september
2020 there was another object found that
was pushed away from the sun
by reflecting sunlight and then without
a cometary tail it was discovered by the
same telescope in hawaii
pan stars and was given the name 2020
so and then the astronomers realized
actually
it's a rocket booster that we launched
uh in 1966 in a lunar landing
mission and we know that this object had
very thin walls and that's why
it had a lot of area for its mass and it
could be pushed by reflecting sunlight
and we definitely know that it was
artificial in origin
and that's why i didn't show commentary
tale
because we produced it uh the question
is
who produced and my point is
that just like bless pascal the
philosopher
argued that you know we cannot ignore
the question of whether god exists
because
pascal was a mathematician and he said
okay logically there are two
possibilities
either god exists or not and we can't
ignore the possibility that god exists
because the implications are huge
and so my argument is very similar the
possibility that umua
is a technological relic uh carries
such great consequences for humanity
that
we should not ignore it many of my
colleagues in academia
dismiss that possibility they say we
need extraordinary evidence before we
even engage in such a discussion
and my point is requiring extraordinary
evidence is
in a way of brushing it aside it's a
sort of a self-fulfilling
prophecy if you're not funding research
that
looks for additional evidence
it's sort of like stepping on the grass
and claiming the grass doesn't grow
because for example to detect
gravitational waves
required an investment of 1.1 billion
dollars by the national science
foundation
we we would never discover gravitational
waves unless we invested that amount
uh to search for dark matter we invested
hundreds of
millions of dollars so far we didn't
find what the dark matter is
it's a search in the dark but without
the investment of funds we will never
find
so on the one hand the scientific
community puts
almost no funding towards the search for
technological relics
and at the same time argues oh the
evidence is
is not sufficiently extraordinary for us
to consider that possibility in the
first place
and i think that's a sign of arrogance
uh it's a very presumptuous statement
to say we are unique and special
there is nothing like us in the universe
i think a much more reasonable
down-to-earth kind of
approach is a modest approach basically
saying
look the conditions on earth
are reproducing in tens of billions of
planets
within the milky way galaxy alone we
know that from the kepler satellite
about half of the sun-like stars have a
planet the size of the earth
roughly at the same separation and that
means that
not only we are not at the center of the
universe like
aristotle argued we are also what we
find in our backyard
is not privileged uh there are lots of
sun earth systems out there
and if you arrange for similar
circumstances you might as well get
similar outcomes
and actually most of the stars from
billions of years before the sun
and so that to me indicates that there
could have been
a lot of technological civilization like
ours
that launched equipment into space just
like we launched the voyager 1 voyager 2
new horizons
and we just need to look for it even if
these civilizations are dead
you know we can do space archaeology and
what i
what i mean by that is you know when i
go to the kitchen
and i find an ant i i get alarmed
because there must be many more ants out
there
so we found the muammua to me it means
that
there must be many more out there and
the weird objects that do not look like
a comet or an asteroid
that we have seen before within the
solar system
and we should search for them for
example in a couple of years there would
be
the vera rubin observatory that will be
much more sensitive than the pan stars
telescope and could find one such
omomura like object every month
so when we find one that approaches us
and we have an alert of a year or so
we can send a spacecraft equipped with a
camera
that will take a close-up photograph of
that
object and perhaps even land on it just
like osiris-rex
landed on the asteroid bennu recently
and collected the sample from it
because you know they say a picture is
worth
a thousand words in my case a picture is
worth 66 000 words the number of words
in my book
if we had a photograph i wouldn't need
to write the book
it would be obvious whether it's a rock
or an artificial object and if it is
artificial and we land on it
we can read off the label made on planet
x
and even import the technology that we
find there
to earth and you know if it's a
technology representing our future let's
say a million years into our future
it will save us a lot of time it will
give us a technological leap
and it could be worth a lot of money all
right so so that's an excellent overview
i think of a really good chunk of the
the the conversation right so
there's this there's this first part of
an interstellar object called the
moammoa entering
the solar system in in 2017 and then
there are lots of parameters about
and properties of this object which are
not easily readily
explainable as an asteroid or as a
comment
as a comet uh some of these things that
we'll discuss are for example like its
rotation its brightness
variation its size its shape how it was
accelerating on its way out
um and then
you know the noticing of this object is
happening
in a scientific context which has some
sense of of arrogance
of um not being fully open to exploring
um hypotheses that um
seem a bit too weird or too far out
there like people are
much more comfortable trying to explain
it as some kind of like
loose aggregate of like a cosmic dust
bunny
or other things which don't really fit
or match the evidence
right and so then
you argue that if we are if if we look
into this with humility
and you know epistemic humility then
if we follow the evidence it takes us to
having a reasonable amount of credence
that this is actually uh artificial in
origin rather than something
natural and then that brings up
questions of
other kinds of life and the drake
equation and
um what it is that we might find in the
universe and how to conduct
space archaeology so to start off i'm
curious if you could
explain a bit more of these particular
properties
that omomoa had and why it is the
uh a natural origin isn't convincing to
you
right i basically followed the evidence
i didn't have any agenda
and in fact i worked on the universe
the early universe and the black holes
throughout most of my career and
then came along this object and was
quite unusual a decade earlier i
predicted how many
rocks from other stars should we expect
to find
and then that was the first paper
predicting that
uh and we predicted that the pan stars
telescope that discovered
will not find anything and the
the mere detection of was a surprise
by orders of magnitude i should say uh
and it is still a surprise
given what we know about the solar
system the number of rocks that the
solar system produced
but nevertheless that was the first
unusual fact
uh but it still allowed for obuamua to
be a rock
and then it didn't show any cometary
tail and the splits of space
telescope put very tight limits
on any carbon-based molecules in its
vicinity or any dust particles and
it was definitely clear that it's not a
comet because
uh if you wanted to explain the excess
push that it exhibited
away from the sun through cometary
evaporation
you needed about a tenth ten percent of
the mass of this object
to be evaporated and that's a lot of
mass we would have seen it
the object size is of order the size of
a football field
100 to 200 meters and we would see
such evaporation easily so
that implied that it's not a comet and
then if it's
not the rocket effect that is pushing it
through evaporation
the question question arose as to what
actually
triggers that push and um the suggestion
that
we made in the paper is that it's the
reflection of sunlight and
for that to be effective you needed the
object to be very thin
the other aspect of the object that was
unusual is that as it was tumbling
the every eight hours the amount of
sunlight reflected from it
changed by a factor of ten and that
implied that
the object has an extreme shape most
likely pancake shape
the flat
not cigar shape the the depiction of the
object as a cigar was based on the fact
that projected on the sky
as it was tumbling the area that it
showed us changed by a factor of 10 so
then of course if you look at the piece
of paper
tumbling in the wind and you look at it
on this
when it's sideways uh it does look like
a cigar
but intrinsically it's flat and that is
at the 90 percent confidence when trying
to model
the amount of light reflected from it as
it was tumbling
uh the conclusion was at the 90
confidence that it should be
pancake shape flat which again is
unusual you don't get such objects very
often
uh in the context of rocks and the most
that we have seen before was
of the order of a factor of three in
length
versus width um and then
uh came the the fact that it originated
from a special frame of reference called
the local standard of rest
which is sort of like the local parking
lot of the milky way galaxy
um if you think about it the stars are
moving relative to each other in the
vicinity of the sun
just like cars moving relative to each
other in the center of a town
and then there is a parking lot that
you can get to when you average over the
motions of all the stars in the vicinity
of the sun and
that is called the local standard of
rest and um originated at rest
in that frame and that's very unusual
because only one in 500 stars
is so much at rest in that frame so more
was
so first it tells you it didn't
originate from any of the nearby stars
also not likely from any of the far away
stars because they are
moving even faster relative to us if
they are far away because of the
rotation around the center of the milky
way galaxy
so it was not
a natural result to get a very
small likelihood to have an object that
is so rare
uh but it's so it was sort of like a
beauty sitting at rest on the surface of
the ocean
and the sun bumped into it like a giant
ship
and the the question is uh if it's
artificial in origin
why would it originate from that frame
and
one possibility is that uh it's a member
of a group
of objects on a grid that serve for
navigation purposes if you want to know
your coordinates as you're navigating in
interstellar space
uh you find your location relative to
this grid
uh and and obviously you want uh
those objects uh to be stationary
uh to be at rest uh relative to the
local frame
of the galaxy uh and then another
possibility is that it's
a member of relay stations for
communication
so to save on the power needed for
transmission of signals you may have
relay stations like we have on earth and
it's one of them
we don't know the purpose of this object
because we don't have enough data on it
that's why we need to find more of the
same but
my basic point is
there were six anomalies of this object
that i did
in my book extraterrestrial and i also
wrote about in scientific american
and these six anomalies make it
very unusual if you assign a probability
of one percent
to the object uh having each of these
anomalies
when you multiply them you get a
probability of one in a trillion
uh that this object is something that we
have seen before so clearly it's
it's very different from what we have
seen before and the
uh response of the scientific community
was to dismiss the artificial origin and
then
there were some uh scientists that took
uh
the scientific process more seriously
and tried to explain
the origin of a momoa from a natural
source and they suggested four
possibilities
after my paper came out one of them was
maybe it's a hydrogen iceberg
a chunk of frozen hydrogen and
that we've never seen before by the way
and then the idea is that when hydrogen
evaporates
you don't see the cometary tail because
it's transparent
uh the problem with that idea is that a
hydrogen evaporates very easily
so we showed in a follow-up paper that
such a chunk of frozen hydrogen the size
of the football field
would not survive the journey through
interstellar space from its birth site
to the solar system and then there was
another suggestion maybe it's a nitrogen
iceberg
that was chipped off the surface of a
planet like pluto
uh and then we showed in a follow-up
paper that in fact
uh you need more uh mass in
mass in the in heavy elements than you
find
in all the stars in the milky way galaxy
by
orders of magnitude more uh just
to have a large enough population of uh
of nitrogen icy objects
in space to explain the the the
discovery of
and the reason is that there is a very
thin layer of nitrogen
solid nitrogen on the surface of pluto
and that makes a small fraction of the
mass budget of
the solar system and so you just cannot
imagine
making enough chunks even if you rip off
all the uh nitrogen on the surface of
exoplutos uh it just doesn't work out
this scenario
and then there was a suggestion maybe
it's a dust bunny as you mentioned
a cloud of dust particles very loosely
bound
and it needs to be a hundred times less
dense than air
so that when reflecting sunlight it will
be pushed like a feather
and the problem with that idea is that
such a cloud would get heated by
hundreds of degrees when it gets close
to the sun and they would not maintain
its integrity so
that also has a problem and the final
suggestion was maybe it's a
a fragment a shrapnel from a bigger
object that passed close to a star and
the problem with that is
the chance of passing close to a star is
very small most objects do not
so why should we see the first
interstellar object as being
is belonging to that to that category
and the second is when you
tidally disrupt a big object when
passing through
near a star the fragments usually get
elongated and
not the pancake shape you get often a
cigar shaped object
so all of these suggestions have major
flaws and
my argument was simple if it's nothing
like we have seen before
we better live on the table the
possibility that it's artificial
and then take a photograph of future
objects that appear as weirdest as this
one
so so you mentioned the local standard
of rest which is the
the average velocity of our local group
is that right
our local group of stars yes uh well
it's the frame that you get to
uh after you average over the motions of
all the stars relative to the sun yes
okay um and so um
was uh at the
the local standard of rest until the
sun's gravitation
pulled it in is that right well no so
the way to think of it it was
um sitting at rest in that frame and
just like a dewey on the surface of the
ocean and then
the sun happened to bump into it the sun
simply
intercepted it along this path and
as a result gave it a kick just like a
ship gives a kick to a buoy
uh the sun acted on it through its
gravitational force primarily
and then in addition there was this
success push which was a small
fraction of the gravitational force just
a
fraction of a percent right and that's
the that's the sun pushing on it through
its large
it's suspected large surface area and
yeah so in addition to gravity there was
an extra
force acting on it which was a small
correction to the force of gravity
uh of the order of a tenth of a percent
and uh
but it's still it was detected at very
high significance because because we
monitor
the motion of and to explain this force
given that there was no cometary
evaporation
uh you needed a thin object and as i
said there was another
thin object uh discovered in september
2020
called 2020 so that also exhibited an
excess push by reflecting sunlight so
it doesn't mean necessarily that umua
was a light sail
it just means that it had a large area
for its mass
can you explain why the smooth
acceleration of umuamua was
was significant yeah so uh
what we detected is
excess acceleration away from the sun
that declines inversely with distance
squared
in a smooth fashion and
first of all the inverse square
law is indicative of
um
a force that acts on the surface of the
object
and the reflection of sunlight is
exactly
giving you that and the fact that it's
smooth
uh cannot be easily mimicked by
commentary of operation because often
you have jets these are spots on the
surface of a comet
from where the evaporation takes off and
and that introduces jitter as the object
tumbles
there is a jitter introduced to its
motion
because of the localized nature of these
jets that are pushing it
you can think of the jets as the jets in
in a plane that
pushed the airplane forward by ejecting
gas backwards but
in the case of a comet the comet is also
tumbling and spinning and
so that introduces some jitter because
the jets are exposed to sunlight
at different phases of this the spin of
the object
and moreover beyond a certain distance
water does not sublimate does not
evaporate anymore you have water ice on
the surface and
beyond a certain distance it doesn't get
heated enough
to evaporate so the push that you get
from
cometary evaporation has a
sharp cut off beyond a certain distance
and
that was not observed in the case of a
muammar there was a smooth
uh push that didn't really cut off
didn't show an abrupt
change at the distance where
water ice would stop evaporating and so
that again is consistent with the
reflection of sunlight being the origin
of the excess push
can you explain the difference between
comets and asteroids
yeah so we're talking about the the
bricks that were left over from the
construction
project of the solar system so
the way that the planets form is that
first you make a star like the sun
and you make it from a cloud of gas
that condenses and collapses
under the influence of itself gravity
its own gravitational force contracts it
and it cools
and makes a star in the middle but uh
some of the gas has rotation around the
center
and so when you make a star like the sun
a small fraction of the
gas of the order of a few percent or so
it remains in a leftover disc around the
star that was
just formed and uh that debris
of gas in the disc is
the birthplace of uh the planets and
that disk of gas that is left over from
the formation process of the sun of
course
includes hydrogen and helium the main
elements from which
the sun is made but also includes heavy
elements and
and they condense in the midplane of the
disc and make dust particles that get
that stick to each other get bigger and
bigger over time
and that they make the so-called
planetesimals
these are the building blocks the bricks
that come together
in making planets like the earth uh
or the core of jupiter that accreted the
also hydrogen and helium around
the central rocky region
so the idea is that you have all these
bricks that
just like lego pieces make up the
planets and some of them get scattered
during the formation process of the
planets and they remain as
uh rocks uh in the outer solar system
you know so the solar system actually
extends
a thousand times farther than the
location of the most distant planet
uh in a region called the or cloud that
extends to a hundred thousand
times the earth sun separation and and
that is a huge volume it goes
halfway to the nearest star so in fact
if you imagine each star having an
oort cloud of these bricks these
building blocks that were scattered
out of the construction process of the
planets around the star
then these ore clouds are touching each
other just like densely packed billiard
poles so
just imagine a sphere of a spherical
region of
planetesimas these rocks and so
comets are those rocks that are covered
with
water ice um so since they're so far
away from the sun the ice freezes
the water freezes on their surface but
some of them
have orbits that bring them very close
to the sun so when they get close to the
sun
the ice the water ice evaporates
and creates a cloud of gas
a water vapor and some dust
that was embedded in in this
rock and that creates this appearance of
a cometary
tail so what you see is the object is
moving and then
its surface layers get heated up by
absorbing sunlight and the gas and dust
evaporate and
create this hello around the object
and a tail uh that always points away
from the sun because it's calmed by
uh the solar wind the the
wind coming from the sun and then so
you end up with a cometary tail that's
what a comet is
now some rocks were made
you know remained closer to to the sun
and
are are not covered with with ice
whatsoever so
they're just bare rocks and when they
get close to the sun
you know there is no ice that evaporates
from them these are called asteroids
and they are just rock without any ice
on the surface and uh so
we see those as well there is actually a
region where asteroids it's called the
main belt of asteroids that's
we don't know what the origin of that is
it could be a planet that was
um disintegrated or it could be a region
that didn't
quite make a planet and you ended up
with uh
fragments floating there uh but at any
event there are asteroids bare rocks
without ice
on them because they were closer close
enough to the sun that the ice
evaporated we don't have the water there
um
and then these objects are also seen in
the vicinity
uh of the earth every now and then these
are called asteroids and
we see basically two populations now um
was not a comet because we haven't seen
a cometary tail around it
uh and it wasn't an asteroid because
there was this excess push if you have
if you have a piece of rock it will not
be pushed much
by reflecting sunlight because its area
is not big enough relative to its mass
so it does
it gets a push but it's too small for it
to show it to exhibit it in its
trajectory
can you also explain how much we know
about the composition
of work clouds and specifically
the shape and size of the kinds of
objects
there and how umuamua relates to our
expectation of what exists in
the orc cloud of different stars yeah so
the one thing
that i should point upfront is when
scientists that try to attend to the
anomalies of
suggest that it's a hydrogen iceberg
or a nitrogen iceberg by the way that
notion
gathered uh popularity in the mainstream
people said oh they they had a sigh of
relief
we can explain this object with
something we know
but the truth is it's not something we
know we've never seen a nitrogen iceberg
that was chipped off pluto in our solar
system
the old cloud does not have nitrogen
icebergs
that we witnessed so claiming that omua
the first interstellar object is a
nitrogen iceberg
or a hydrogen iceberg implies that there
are nurseries
out there around other stars or in
molecular clouds
that are completely different than
the solar system in the sense that
they produced most of the interstellar
objects because of
mo was the first one we discovered so
they produce a large fraction of the
interstellar objects
yet they are completely different
from the solar system it's just like
going
you know to the hospital and seeing a
baby
that looks completely different than
any child you have seen before at your
home
you know from any child you had and
it implies that the birthplace of that
child was quite different
but yet that child appears to be the
first one you see
so you know that's to me an important
signal from nature that you know you
have to rethink
what the meaning of this discovery is
and and the other
message is we will learn something new
no matter what
so we need to get more data on the next
object that belongs to this
family because even if it's a naturally
produced object
it will teach us about environments that
produce objects
that are quite different from the ones
we find in the solar system
and that means that we missed something
about the
nature and even if it's natural in
origin we learn
something really new in the in the
process of gathering this data so
we should not dismiss this object and
say
business as usual we don't have to worry
about it
rather we should attempt to collect as
much data as possible
on the next weird object that comes
along i should say there was a second
interstellar object discovered
by an amateur astronomer from
russia called gennady borisov and it was
given the name borisov discovered in
2019
that one looked just like a comet and i
was asked
does that convince you that the muammar
was also natural because this one looks
exactly like the comets we have seen
and i replied you know when you go along
the beach
and most of the time you see
rocks and suddenly you see a plastic
bottle
and after that you see rocks the fact
that
you found rocks afterwards doesn't make
the plastic bottle a rock
you know each object has to be
considered on its own
merit and uh therefore
it makes omumu even more unusual
the fact that we see borisov as a
natural comet
so um in terms of the objects that come
from the or cloud our on our cloud there
is a size distribution that
there are objects that are much smaller
than ammo
and objects that are much bigger and of
course the bigger objects are more rare
and roughly speaking there is equal
amount of mass
per logarithmic size bin
so there are many more small objects
and most of them we can't see because
um was roughly at the limit of our
sensitivity with pan stars and that
means that objects much smaller
than the size of a football field cannot
be noticed
within a distance comparable to the
distance to the sun
the sun acts as a lamppost you know
that illuminates the darkness around us
and so an object is detected when it
reflects enough sunlight for us to
detect
with our telescopes and so small objects
do not reflect enough sunlight
and we will notice them but i calculated
that in fact
if there are probes moving very fast
through the solar system let's say at a
fraction of the speed of light
that were sent by some alien
civilizations
we could detect the emission from them
the infrared emission from them with the
james webb space telescope
they would move very fast across our sky
so
we just need to be ready to detect them
do you think that the given our limited
knowledge of oort clouds
that there are perhaps like exotic
objects or rare objects which we you
know haven't encountered yet but that
are natural in origin
um that may account for for a moment
of course there could be uh as i
mentioned that people suggested the
hydrogen iceberg nitrogen iceberg
dust bunny you know these were
suggestions that were already made and
each of them has its own
challenges and it could be something
else of course
and the way to find out that's the way
science
operates you know the science is guided
by
evidence by collecting data and
the way you know science should be done
is you leave all possibilities
on the table and then you collect enough
data to rule out
all but one interpretation that looks
most plausible
and so my argument is we should leave
the artificial origin
possibility on the table because all the
other possibilities that were
contemplated
uh invoke something that we've never
seen before
so we cannot argue based on
you know speculations that it's
something that we've never seen before
we cannot argue that proves the point
that it's not artificial
right so um it's a very simple point
that i'm making and i'm
arguing for collecting more data i mean
i would be happy to be proven wrong that
it's not
artificial in origin and then move on uh
the point is that science is not done by
having a prejudice knowing the answer in
advance it's done by collecting data and
you know the mistake uh that was made by
the philosophers during galileo's time
is not to look through his telescope
and argue that they know that the sun
moves around the earth
and that only maintained their ignorance
uh
reality doesn't care whether we ignore
it
you know the earth continued to move
around the sun if we have neighbors
uh you know they exist out there and it
doesn't really matter whether we
shut down the the curtains on our
windows and claim no we are unique
and special and there is nobody out
there on the street
the fact that we say that you know we
can get a lot of
likes on twitter saying that and we can
ridicule anyone that
uh argues uh differently but that would
not change the fact whether we have
neighbors or not
that's an empirical fact and in order
for us to
uh improve our knowledge of reality i'm
talking about reality not about
philosophical arguments
just figuring out whether we have
neighbors whether we
are the smartest kid on the block you
know that's
within the realm of science and
uh finding out the answer to this
question is not a matter of debate
it's a matter of collecting evidence but
of course if you are not
willing to see to find wonderful things
you will never discover them so
my point is we should consider this
possibility
as real as very plausible as mainstream
activity
just like the search for dark matter or
the search for gravitational waves you
know
we exist there are many planets out
there just like the earth
therefore we should search for things
like us that existed
or exist on them that's a very simple
assumption to make an argument to make
and to me it sounds like this should be
a mainstream activity
but then i realized that my colleagues
do not agree and
i i failed to understand this this
dismissal because
it's a subject of great interest to the
public and the public funds science
so uh you know if you go back a thousand
years there were people saying
the human body has a soul and therefore
anatomy should be forbidden so imagine
if scientists would say oh this is a
controversial subject the human body
could have a soul
we don't want to deal with that because
some people are claiming that we should
not operate
the human body where would modern
medicine be
my argument is if science has the tool
to address the subject of great interest
to the public
we have an obligation to address it and
clear it up
let's do it bravely with open eyes and
by the way there is an added bonus if
the public cares about it
there will be funding for it so how is
it possible that the scientific
community ridicules this subject
brushes it aside claims we don't
want to entertain this unless we have
extraordinary evidence
yet fails to fund at a very substantial
level
the search for that extraordinary
evidence how is that possible in the
21st century
so given the the evidence and data that
we do have
what is your credence that omua mua is
alien in origin
well i i have no certainty in that
possibility but i say
it's a possibility that should be put
left on the table
uh with at least as high likelihood as
a nitrogen iceberg or a hydrogen iceberg
or a dust bunny that's what i consider
the
competing interpretations i don't
consider statements like
it's always rocks it's never aliens
as valid scientific statements
because they remind me of the
possibility you know if you were to
present a cell phone
to a caveman and the caveman is used to
playing with rocks
all of his life the caveman would argue
that the cellphone is just
a shiny rock and then you know
just basing uh your assertions on past
experience
is no different than what the
philosophers were arguing
we don't want to look through galileo's
telescope because we know that the sun
moves around the earth
so you know this mistake was made over
and over again throughout human history
i would expect modern scientists
to be more open-minded to thinking
outside the box
to entertain possibilities that are you
know
straightforward and what i find is
you know the strange thing is not so
much that there is conservatism
you know regarding this uh subject
but at the same time in theoretical
particle physics
you have whole communities of hundreds
of people
entertaining ideas that have no
experimental verification
no experimental test in the foreseeable
future
whatsoever ideas like uh the string
theory landscape or the multiverse
or some people argue we live in a
simulation or other people
talk about super symmetry and you know
awards
were given to people doing mathematical
gymnastics
and these studies are part of the
mainstream and i asked myself
how is it possible that this is
considered past
part of the mainstream and the search
for technological signatures not
and my answer is that these ideas
provide a sandbox
for people to demonstrate that they're
smart that they're clever and
a lot of the culture in academia is
about that
it's not about understanding nature it's
more about
showing that you're smart and getting
honors and awards
and that's unfortunate because you know
physics and science is a dialogue with
nature
it's a learning experience we're
supposed to listen to nature and the
best way to listen to nature is to look
at anomalies things that do not quite
line up
with what we expected and by the way
whether or
not is artificial or not that doesn't
require very
fancy math it's a very simple fact that
any person can understand and who said i
mean nature is under no obligation
uh to to reveal its most exciting
secrets
without fancy math it doesn't need to be
sophisticated you know
aristotle had this idea of the spheres
surrounding us that we are at the center
of the universe
and there are these beautiful spheres
around us that was a very sophisticated
uh idea that many people liked because
it flattered their ego to be at the
center of the universe and it also had
this
very clever arrangement
but it was wrong so who cares how
sophisticated an idea
is who cares if the math is extremely
complicated
i mean of course it demonstrates that
you're smart if you're able to maneuver
through these
complicated the mathematical gymnastics
but that doesn't mean that it's it's
reflecting reality and
and my point is we better pay attention
to anomalies that nature gives us than
to uh promoting our image so it seems
like there's this
this this is interesting um
i guess i would say difference between
um the extent to which the scientific
community is willing to entertain
omuamua as being artificial in origin
whereas at the same time there's a ton
of theories that at least at the moment
are
unfalsifiable
yet here we have a a a theory that
you know it is simple matches the data
and can be falsified
right and the way to falsify it i mean
it's not by
chasing one more because by now it's a
million times fainter than it was
close to the sun but then it's by
finding more objects
that look as weird as it was you know
this was the first object we identified
there must be many more if if we found
this object over by serving the sky for
a few years
we will definitely find more by serving
the sky for a few more years
uh because of the copernican principle
you know the
copernicus discovered that we are not
positioned in a special location in
privileged location in the universe
we're not at the center of the universe
and you can extend it also not just to
space but also
time and when you make an observation
over a few years time
the chance of these few years being
special and privileged
is small i mean it most likely it's a
typical time and you would find it if
you were to look
at the previous three years or the the
following three years and
that's uh the copernican principle and i
very much subscribe to it because
again the one thing i learned from
practicing astronomy over the decades
uh was a sense of modesty you know we
are we're not special we are not unique
we are not located at the center of the
universe we don't have anything
especially in our backyard the earth sun
system is very common
so that's the message that nature gives
us and you know we are born
into the world like actors put on a
stage
and first thing we see is the stage is
huge
it's 10 to the power 26 times larger
than our body
and the second thing we see is that the
play has been
going on for you know 13.8 billion years
since the big bang
and we just arrived at the end of it so
it's certainly in
the play is not about us we are not the
main actors
so let's get a sense of modesty and
let's look for other actors
that may have been around for longer
than we did as a technological
civilization
maybe they know they have a better sense
of what the play is about
so i think it all starts from a sense of
modesty and
you know my daughters when they were
young they uh
were at home and they had the the
impression that they are the center of
the world that they are the smartest
because they haven't met anyone else
outside the family and
and then when we took them to the
kindergarten they got a better sense of
reality by meeting others and realizing
that they are not necessarily the
the smartest kid on the block and so i
think our civilization has yet to mature
and the best way to do that is by
meeting others
i'm curious if you're willing to offer
like a specific credence
so you said that there are these other
natural theories like the dust bunny and
the
the ice the iceberg theories um
you know if we think of this in terms of
bayesian reasoning
what kind of probability would you
assign to to the
to the alien hypothesis well
the point is that these objects that
were postulated for natural origin of um
were never seen before so there is no
way of assigning likelihood to something
that we've never seen before and it
needs to be the most common object
in interstellar space so what i would
say
is that we should approach it without a
bayesian
prior basically we should leave all
of these possibilities on the table and
then
get as much data as possible on
the next object that shows the same
qualities as
more and by by these qualities i mean
not not having a commentary tell so not
being a comet
and showing an excess push away from the
sun
and as i mentioned there was such an
object 20 20 so
but it was produced by us so we should
just look for more objects that come
from interstellar space that
exhibit these properties and see what
the data tells us
it's not a matter of a philosophical
debate that's my point
we just need a close-up photograph and
we can easily tell the difference
between a rock
and an artificial object and i would
argue that
anyone on earth should be convinced when
we have such a
photograph so
if we can get such a photograph in the
next few years
i would be delighted even if i'm proven
wrong you know because we will learn
something new no matter what
so there's also been a lot of
a lot of energy in the news around
ufo sightings and ufo reports recently
i'm curious how
how the the current news and status of
ufo interest
you know in the united states and the
world how that affects your credence of
umuah being alien in origin and if you
have any
perspective or thoughts on on on ufos
yeah it's a completely independent
set of facts that is
underlying the discussion on ufos but uh
of course
again it's the facts the evidence that
we need to pay attention to i always say
let's keep our eyes on the ball
not on the audience and because if you
look at the audience the scientists are
responding to these ufo reports in
exactly the same ways they responded to
a momoa
they dismiss it they ridicule it
and that's unfortunate because you know
the scientists should ask
could we have access to the data could
we analyze the data could we see the
full data
or could we collect new data on these
objects
so that we can clear up the mystery i
mean science is about evidence it's not
about prejudice but instead
the scientists know the answer in
advance they say
oh these reports are just you know
related to human-made
objects and that's it now let's follow
the logic of sherlock holmes
basically sherlock holmes as i mentioned
in my book extraterrestrial sarah holmes
made the statement that you put all
possibilities on the table and then
whatever remains after you sort out all
the facts
must be the truth that's the way he
operated
as a detective so that's the way we
should operate
as scientists and what do we know about
the latest
ufo report from the pentagon
and uh intelligence agencies
uh so far before a few weeks before it's
being released
we know uh from leaks that
there is a statement that some of the
objects
that were identified that were found
are real okay they are not artifacts of
the cameras
there are not illusions of the people
who saw them because they were detected
by
multiple instruments including infrared
cameras
radar systems optical cameras and
a lot of people from different angles
and when you consider that statement
coming from the pentagon
you have to take it seriously because
it's just the tip of the iceberg that
the data that will be released to the
public
presumably is partial because
they will never release the high quality
data
because it will inform other nations of
the capabilities the kind of sensors
that the u.s
has in monitoring the sky okay so
i'm i have no doubt that a lot of data
is being hidden
for national security reasons because
otherwise it will expose
the capabilities of these sensors that
are being routinely used to monitor the
sky
but if people that had access to the
full data and that includes
you know officials such as former
president barack obama
former cia director james
woolsey and others that saw the data
and they make the case that these
objects are real
then these objects may very well be real
okay and i take that at face value
of course as a scientist i would like to
see the full data
and or collect new data then there is no
difference because
science is about reproducibility of
results
so if the data is classified i would
much rather
place state-of-the-art cameras that you
can buy
in the commercial sector and or you know
scientific instrumentation that
that we can purchase and and just place
those uh
in the same locations and and record the
sky you know this
the sky is not classified in principle
anyone can collect data about the sky
so i would argue that you know if the
all data is classified we should
collect new data that will be open to
the public
and it's not a huge investment of funds
to to have such an experiment
but the point of the matter is that we
can
infer if the objects are real and
using the scientific method then let's
assume that they're real like
the people that saw the full data claim
so if they are real then there are three
possibilities
either they were produced manufactured
by
other nations because we certainly know
what we are doing
the us uh so if they were produced by
other nations like
china or russia
then humans have the ability to produce
such objects
and they cannot exceed the limits
of our technologies and if the
maneuvering of these objects
looked as if they exceed substantially
the limits of the technologies we
possess
then we would argue it's not made by by
humans because
there is no way that the secret about
an advanced technology uh
would be preserved uh on earth
by humans because it has huge benefits
commercially you know so it would appear
in the market in the commercial sector
uh
because you can sell it for a lot of
money or it would appear in the
battlefield
if it's being used by other nations and
we pretty much know what humans are
capable of producing
because we would we are also probably
getting intelligence
on other nations so we know
what are the limits of human technology
i don't think the you know we can leave
that possibility
uh vague uh if there is an object
behaving in a way that
far exceeds what we are able
to produce then that looks
quite intriguing and then the question
is
that the remaining possibilities are
that somehow
it's a phenomenon that occurs in the
earth atmosphere
there is something that happens that um
you know we didn't identify before or
that these are objects that came from
an extraterrestrial origin okay and
once again i i make the case that the
way to make progress
on this is not to appear on twitter and
claim we know the answer in advance and
ridicule
the other side of the argument this is
not the way by which we make progress
but rather collect better
evidence better clues and figure it out
clear up the fog
you know it's not a mystery that should
be
unraveled by philosophical arguments
it's something that you can measure
and get data on and reproduce with
future
experiments and once we get that
we will have a clear a clearer view of
what it means
and then that's how mysteries get
resolved in science
so i would argue for a scientific
experiment that will clear up the fog
and the way that we will not do that is
if
the scientific community would ridicule
these reports
and the public would
speculate about the possible
interpretations that's the worst
situation you can be
in because you're basically living a
subject of great interest to the public
unresolved and that's not
the right way you know again in the 21st
century to
treat a subject of interest to the
public
that obviously reaches the congress you
know that
it's not an eyewitness on the street
that says i saw something unusual it's
you know it's military personnel
we have to take it seriously and we have
to get to the bottom of it
so that's the way i i look at it and you
know it may well be that it's not
the extraterrestrial in origin but i
think the key is by finding evidence
so given the age of the universe
and the age of our galaxy and the age of
our solar system
would you be surprised if there were
alien artifacts
almost everywhere or in in many places
but we were just really bad at finding
them
or those artifacts were really good at
hiding no i wouldn't be surprised
because as i said most of the stars from
billions of years before the sun
and if there were technological
civilizations around them you know some
of many of these stars
died by now and these civilizations may
have
perished but if they send equipment
that equipment may operate especially if
it's
you know being operated by artificial
intelligence or by
um things that we haven't invented yet
uh it may well survive billions of years
and and
you know get to our environment now
one thing you have to realize is when
you go in the wilderness
you better be quiet you better not make
a sound
and listen because there may be
predators out there
now we have not been careful in that
sense because we have been broadcasting
radio waves
for more than a century so these
radio signals reached 100 light years by
now and
if there is another advanced
civilization out there with radio
telescopes
of the type that we possess they may
already
know about us and then if they use
chemical rockets to get back to us
it would take them a million years to
traverse a hundred light years
but if they use much faster propulsion
they may be already here and
the question is um you know
are we noticing them you know there was
this
fermi paradox formulated 70 years ago by
enrico fermi a famous physicist
who said that where is everybody
and of course that's a presumptuous
statement
because it assumes that we are
sufficiently interesting for them to
come and visit us
and you know when i met my wife she had
a lot of friends that
were waiting for prince charming on a
white horse to
make them a marriage proposal and that
never happened and then they compromised
them
we as a civilization uh you know would
be presumptuous in
assuming that we are sufficiently
interesting for others to have a party
in our backyard uh but nevertheless
you know it could be that it already
happened
as you said and we didn't notice uh
one thing to keep in mind is the
through geological activity most of the
surface of the earth
uh gets mixed with the interior of the
earth
over a hundred million years time scale
so
uh it could be that some of the evidence
was buried
uh by the geological activity on earth
and that's why we don't see it but the
moon
for example is like a museum because
it doesn't have geological activity and
also it doesn't have an atmosphere that
would burn up an object that is smaller
than the size of a person like the
earth's atmosphere does
for meteors so in principle once we
establish a sustainable base on the moon
you know we can regard it as an
archaeological site
and survey the surface of the moon to
look for
artifacts that may have landed may have
crashed on it
maybe we will find a piece of equipment
that we never sent
that came from somewhere else that
crashed on the surface of the moon
it'd be wonderful if we could pivot into
great filters and space archaeology here
but
before we do that i'm curious if you're
talking about the fermi paradox and
whether or not we're
sufficiently interesting to
merit the attention of other alien
civilizations
i i wonder if interesting is really the
the right criteria right because you
know if
if advanced civilizations converge on
some form of of ethics or beneficence
then
whether or not it's interesting is
whether or not we're interesting is not
perhaps the right criteria for whether
or not they would reach out like
we have people on earth who are
interested in animal ethics like how
the ants and bees and and other animals
are doing so
it could be the same case with with with
aliens right
right i completely agree um
one thing i should say well actually two
things
first you mentioned before the drake's
equation um
it doesn't apply to relics it doesn't
apply to objects the direct equation
talks about
uh the likelihood of detecting radio
signals and
you know that has been the method we
used over the past 70 years
in searching for other civilizations and
i think it's misguided because
in order to get a signal it's just like
trying to have
a phone conversation you need the
counterpart to be alive
and it's quite possible that most of the
civilizations are dead by now
so that's the great filter idea that
there is a
narrow window of opportunity for us to
communicate with them
but uh on the other hand they may have
sent
equipment into space and we can search
for it through space archaeology
and find relics from civilizations that
are not around anymore
just like we find relics from cultures
that existed on the surface of earth
through archaeological digs so i think a
much more promising approach to find
evidence for dead civilizations
is looking for objects floating in space
and the calculation
of what's the likelihood of finding them
is completely different from the
drake equation it's it resembles more
the calculation of you know what's the
chance that you will stumble across a
plastic bottle on the beach
or on the surface of the ocean and you
just need to know
how many plastic bottles are per unit
area
on the surface of the ocean and then you
will know what's the likelihood of
crossing one of them and the same is
true for relics in space you just need
to be
you know the number of such objects per
unit volume
and then you will figure out what's your
chance of bumping into one of them
and that's a completely different
calculation than the drake equation
which
talks about receiving radio signals
so um yeah and the other point that i
would like
to mention is that when
during our childhood we always have a
sense of
adults looking over our shoulders
and then making sure that everything
goes well and
they often protect us and then
as we become independent and
grow up we are
we encounter reality uh on our own
and this there is this longing
for a a higher power
that overlooks our shoulder and you know
that is
provided by the idea of god
in religion but interestingly enough
it's also related to the idea
of some unidentified flying objects
that are looking over our shoulders
because
if a ufo was identified
to be of extraterrestrial origin
it may imply that there is
an adult wiser than we are
in the room looking over our shoulder
the question of
whether that adult is trying to protect
us
uh is still open remains open but we can
be optimistic
let's talk a little bit about whether or
not there might be adults
in the room um so you
you defined what a great filter was um
usually my understanding so when i think
of great filters i think of
there being potentially many of them
rather than a single great filter
so there's the birth of the universe and
then you need
generations of stars to fuse heavier
elements
and then there's the number of planets
in goldilocks zones and then there's
abiogenesis or the arising of life on
earth and then there's
moving from single to multicellular life
and then there's
intelligent life and civilization et
cetera right so it seems like there's a
lot of different places where there
could be
great filters could you could you
explain your perspective
on um you know where you think the
most likely great filters might be well
i think it's self-destruction because
i was asked by harvard alumni
how much longer do i expect our
civilization to survive
and i said um you know when you look at
your life and you just select a random
day
throughout your life what's the chance
that it's the first day after you are
born
that probability is
tens of thousands of times smaller
than the probability that the day you
select would be
during your adulthood because there are
tens of thousands
of days in the life of an adult
so we existed for
about a century as an advanced
technological civilization
and you ask yourself okay well if we are
in our adulthood which is the most
probable state for us to be in as i
mentioned before
you're just sampling randomly a time and
most likely during your adulthood
then that means that we have only a few
more centuries left
because the likelihood that we will
survive for millions of years
is tens of thousands of times smaller
it would imply that we are in the first
day of our life
and that is unlikely now
the one caveat i have to this statement
is
that the human spirit
can defy all odds so i believe that in
principle if we get our act together
we can be an outlier in the statistical
likelihood function and that's my hope
i'm an optimist and i hope that we will
get our act together but if we continue
to behave the way we are
not to care so much about the climate
you can even see it in world politics
nowadays
um even when you have administrations
that care about climate
they cannot really convince the
commercial sector to cooperate
and suppose our civilization is on
a path to self-destruct
then we don't have more than a few
centuries left
so that is a great filter and of course
there could be many other great filters
but that seems to me as the most serious
one and then
i would say you know that they're
then you ask yourself okay so which
civilization is more likely to survive
it's probably the dumber civilization
that doesn't create the
technologies that destroy it you know
like if you have a bunch of crocodiles
swimming on the surface of a planet
you know they will not create an atomic
weapon
they would not change the climate
so they may survive for billions of
years who knows
so maybe the most common civilizations
are the dumb ones
but uh one thing to keep in mind are
is that um when you create
technological capabilities you can
create equipment that will
reproduce itself like for neumann
machines
or you can send it to space you can
escape from the
location that you were born on
and and so that opens up a whole range
of opportunities in space
and that's why i say that once a
civilization
uh ventures into space
then everything is possible then you can
fill up space
with equipment that reproduces itself
and there could be a lot of plastic
bottles out there
and we don't know we shouldn't assume
anything we should just
search for them and the um
as far as i'm concerned was a wake-up
call
and the other thing i would like to say
is
if i imagine a very advanced
civilization
you know that understands how to unify
quantum mechanics with
gravity something we don't possess at
the moment
such a unification scheme that we know
works
perhaps they know how to irritate the
vacuum and create a baby universe
that would lead to more civilization so
it's
just like having a baby that can make
babies
that can make babies and you would get
many generations as a result of that so
if you this could be an origin of the
big bang
you know maybe the umbilical cord of the
big bang started
in a laboratory and
by the way it would say that
intelligence you know technological
advance
is an approximation to god because you
know in
in the religious stories god created the
universe we can imagine a technology
that would create a baby universe
and then the same is true for life you
know we don't know if life was
seeded the origins of life was seated in
a laboratory somewhere
and so that remains a possibility and
that's
what's so fascinating about the search
for intelligent life out there because
it may provide answers to the most
fundamental questions we have like the
meaning of life
would you consider your argument there
about human extinction uh given
what we are currently observing is is
that like the doomsday argument
yeah well you can call it the doomsday i
would
call it um risk assessment and then
the question is how i don't think we are
statistical
systems in the sense that there is no
escape
from a particular future because i think
that once we recognize
the risk in a particular future we can
respond
and avoid it the only question is
whether as a civilization will be
intelligent enough and
frankly you know i'm worried
that we are not intelligent enough and
it may be just like a darwinian
principle where you know if you're not
intelligent enough you will not survive
uh and you know we will never be
admitted
to the club of intelligent civilizations
in the milky way galaxy unless we change
our behavior
and um it's yet to be seen
whether we will change our behavior
accordingly and
one way to convince people to change
their behavior
is to find evidence for other
civilizations that didn't
and perished as a result that would be a
warning for us
a history lesson so this this first
point
gets into what i understand to be as
anthropics
so anthropics is is like motivated by
the
observation selection effect which says
that
the kinds of observations that observers
can make is limited by the fact that
they
are observers so there's this older
argument about the universe being finely
tuned
but you know of course observers are
only going to be making observations of
universes in which they
can be observers right and so we're also
in the goldilocks zone of a star
so you know observers will only make
observations on planets where
uh they can arise and so then
you know there's this perspective of
taking this line of argument towards
existential risk from from technology or
for example the
the lifespan of the species and and
where we find ourselves and what that
means about
human extinction um this isn't this
really isn't something that i understand
very well but but something about
anthropics and this
this uh doomsday argument or i think
what you call like a risk analysis
argument something
something that feels really like fishy
to me
i'm not sure what it is it's something
about like you know every op
every observer is going to make like
you're going to find yourself at every
point in the timeline at like
some point in time so i find it
difficult to like
someone 300 000 years ago could have
reasoned the same well a hundred
thousand years ago could
reason the same way well but the
difference is that
like animals or we as a civilization a
hundred thousand years ago
we could not change the conditions on
our planet
we could not go into space right but
it's just a statistical argument
but i'm saying um we only were able to
do that over the past century and
that makes it a very special period um
it's a small fraction of the age of the
of the earth now one caveat i i should
mention is
we always imagine things like us you
know and
when we go to meet someone it's a fair
assumption to assume that that person
has
eyes and nose and ears the way we have
and the reason it's a reasonable
assumption is because we share the same
genetic
heritage as the person that we are
meeting
but if you think about life on a planet
that had no
causal contact with earth it could be
very different
and so calculating the likelihood
of self-destruction the the likelihood
of life of one
form versus another the likelihood of
intelligence
all of these very often assume something
similar to us
which may not be the case i think it
might be shocking to us to find the
creatures from another planet
or technologies from another planet uh
and so my solution to this ambiguity
is to be an observer you know even
though i'm a theorist
i would argue let's be modest let's not
try to predict things in this context
let's just explore the universe and the
biggest mistake we
we are making over and over again
is to argue about the answer before
seeing the evidence
and that's the biggest mistake because
it convinces you
to be lazy not to collect more evidence
to say i know the answer in advance i
don't need to look through the telescope
i don't need to invest fans in searching
for this
even though it's an important question i
know the answer in advance
and that's the biggest mistake we can
make as a species
i'm you know i'm willing to go through
all the hardships of arguing something
outside the box
of confronting this personal attacks
against me
uh just because it's a question of such
great importance to humanity
you know if that was a minor
question about the nature of dark matter
i would not risk
anything for that you know who cares you
know if the dark matter is axions or
weakly interacting massive particles
that has very little impact on our daily
lives
it's not worth confronting you know
the the mainstream on that uh but
and by the way the response would not be
so emotional in that case either
you know but on a subject as important
as this one
to the future of humanity which is the
title of your organization
there is no doubt in my mind that
it's worth the extra effort it's worth
the hardship
bringing people to recognize that such a
search for technological relics
in space is extremely important
for the way we view ourselves
in the big scheme of things our
aspirations for space
our notions about religion
uh and uh what we
might do in response to the knowledge
that we acquire
you know it will completely change the
future of humanity
and on such a question i'm willing to
put my body on the barbed wire
thank you very much for putting your
body on the barbed wire
um i think i think you mentioned that
there was something in was it israeli
training where where soldiers are taught
to put their body on the barbed wire so
people can climb over them
yeah that was a statement that in the
battlefield very often
a soldier is asked to put his body on
the bad boy so that others can pass
through and you know the way i see it
historically is
you look at socrates uh the ancient
greek
philosopher he advocated for you know
doubting
[Music]
the wisdom of uh influential politicians
at the time and
other important figures and uh
he was blamed for corrupting the youth
by dismissing the gods that were
uh valued by this
um civilians of the uh
city state of athens at the time and
he was uh prosecuted and
forced to drink poison now if socrates
would have lived today he would have
been
cancelled on the athenian
social media that would be the
equivalent of poison
and you see another philosopher epicorus
that
made many true statements
but again was disliked by
some religious authorities at the time
and you see of course galileo galilei
that was put
in house arrest
later on you see giordano bruno
now what he i mean he was an obnoxious
person that was not liked by
a lot of people but
he simply argued that other stars
are just like the sun and therefore they
might have a planet
just like the earth that could have life
on it
and the church at the time found it
offensive because if there is life
that is intelligent out there then
that life may have sinned and then
christ
should have saved that life and then you
need
billions of copies of christ to be
distributed throughout the galaxy
to visit all these planets and that
makes
little sense that made little sense to
the church
and so they burned giordano bruno on a
stake
and um even though nowadays we know that
indeed a lot of stars are like the sun
and a lot of planets
are just like the earth at
roughly the same separation from their
host stars
where life may exist on the surface so
in that sense he was correct um
and obviously you find many such
examples uh also in modern uh
signs in over the past century of people
advocating for the correct ideas and
being dismissed and ridiculed
just to give you an example uh a former
chair of the astronomy department at
harvard that preceded me
i chose astronomy department for nine
years i was the longest serving chair in
the history of the astronomy department
at harvard
before me was cecilia payne kapashkin
and in her phd thesis which was the
first thesis
in astronomy at harvard she argued
based on analyzing the spectrum of the
sun that
most of the surface of the sun is made
of hydrogen
and while defending her phd thesis
henry norris russell who was the
director of the princeton university
observatory an authority
on stars at that time dismissed her idea
and said that is ridiculous because we
know
that the sun is made of the same
elements as the earth
so you know there is not much hydrogen
on earth
it cannot be the case that the sun is
made mostly of hydrogen
so she took out that conclusion from her
phd
and then in the subsequent few years he
redid the analysis got more data and
wrote an extended paper
in the astrophysical journal arguing the
same
that she was correct and
interestingly enough uh in a visiting
committee to the princeton university
department of astrophysics the chair of
that the department
was bragging that henry norris russell
discovered
that the sun is made mostly of hydrogen
so you can see
that history depends pretty much on who
tells it
but the point of the matter is
that sometimes when you propose an idea
that
even though it has to be correct because
it's based on evidence
it's being dismissed by the authorities
and science is not dictated by authority
you know in the 1930s there was a book
co-authored by tens of scientists
arguing that einstein's theory of
relativity must be wrong
and when einstein was asked about it he
said
why do we need tens of scientists to
prove that my theory is wrong
it's enough to have one author that
would explain
why the theory is wrong you know science
is not based on authority
it's based on reasoning and on evidence
and there is a lot of bullying going on
nowadays
and i witness it and throughout my
career
i've seen a number of ideas that i
proposed
that were dismissed and ridiculed at
first
and then they became the interest of
mainstream and now there are hundreds of
people working on them
uh that was true for my work on the
first stars you know i remember that
it was dismissed early on there were
people claiming even that there are no
stars beyond the redshift of two
and then and then i worked on imaging
black holes
i suggested that there could be a
correlation between black hole mass
and the characteristic velocity
dispersion of stars
in the vicinity of those supermassive
black holes at the centers
of galaxies i worked on gravitational
wave astrophysics
long before it was fashionable and in
all of these cases
the interest that i had
early on was ridiculed i gave a a
lecture in a winter school
in 2013 in january 2013
winter school in jerusalem on
gravitational wave astrophysics
and one of the other lecturers
who was who still is 20 years younger
than i am
stood up and said why are you wasting
the time of these young students on a
subject that will not be of
importance in their career and he said
that publicly stood up in front of
everyone it's on video
and two years later two and a half years
later
the ligo experiment detected the first
gravitational wave signal
many of these students were still doing
their phd
and this became the hottest frontier in
astrophysics
in subsequent years and the nobel prize
was awarded so here you have a situation
where someone says
why are you giving a lecture on this
subject to students because it was
it would never be of importance
throughout their careers
and two and a half years later it
becomes the hottest
topic the hottest frontier in
astrophysics
and it involves a new messenger
other than light that was never used
before in astrophysics gravitational
waves ripples in space and time
it opens up a whole new window into the
universe
so how is it possible that someone that
is 20 times younger than i
am you know stands up
feels you know completely feels that
it's completely appropriate for him to
stand up
in front of all the students and say
that
and to me it illustrates
narrow-mindedness it's not
a matter of conservatism it's a matter
of
thinking within the box and not allowing
to think outside the box
and you know that you might say okay
it's acceptable because there are lots
of
people suggesting crazy ideas but at the
same time
you have whole communities of
theoretical physicists working on
very strange ideas that were not
verified experimentally
and that is part of the mainstream and
the common thread
between these two communities of people
is that they both
don't pay attention to evidence
they both do not recognize the fact
that evidence leads the way
in the case of gravitational waves it's
the fact that we detected the signal so
just wait
you know for ligo to find the signal and
then everything will change in the case
of
we saw some anomalies let's pay
attention to them let's talk about them
and in the case of string theory it's
let's say
this should be at the fringes of
mainstream because we haven't found
evidence that supports the idea of extra
dimensions as of yet
so it doesn't deserve to be center stage
but you have these two communities
living side to side because
both of them feel comfortable not paying
attention
to evidence we like to think of
of science as this really clean
epistemic
process of hypothesis
generating and creating theories and
then verification and falsification
through
evidence and data gathering but you know
the reality is
that it's still made up of lots of
humans who
have their own need for recognition
and meaning and acceptance and
validation right and so
in order to improve the the the process
of science it's
it's it's probably helpful to bring
light
to the reality of the you know you know
the humanity that we all still have when
we're engaged in
in the scientific pursuit and that helps
to
you know open our minds to
to the truth when it's when our pursuit
of the truth is not being obscured by
um things we're not being honest with
ourselves about
right and i was
the founding director of the black hole
initiative at the harvard university
which brings together
physicists mathematicians astronomers
and philosophers
and the my motivation in creating this
center was to bring people from
different perspectives
so that they will open the minds uh
of other disciplines uh
two possible breakthroughs um in the
context of black holes and
i think this is key i think we should be
open-minded and we should also fund
risky
propositions risky ideas there should be
a certain fraction of
the funding that goes in those
directions and
you know even though i founded this
black hole initiative in the first
annual conference that we had
a philosopher gave a a lecture and
at the end of the lecture the
philosopher argued that
if after speaking to a lot of string
theories
he made the statement that if a bunch of
physicists
agree on something as being true
for a decade then
it must be true and because physics
is what physicists decide to do
and i raised my hand i said how can you
mix
you know i would expect philosophers to
give us a litmus state
as test of honesty you know it's just
like the canary in a cave they should
tell us
when truth is not being spoken and i
just
couldn't understand how a philosopher
could make such a thing i said there are
many examples in history
where physicists agreed on something and
it was completely wrong
and the only way for us to find out is
by experimental evidence nature is
teaching us
it's a learning experience and you know
we can all agree
that we are the wealthiest people in the
world
and if we go to an atm machine that's
equivalent to doing an experiment and
testing that idea now we can feel happy
until we try to cash
the money out of the atm machine and
then we realized that our ideas
were wrong you know and how do you tell
if someone
mentions an idea how do you tell that
whether it's a ponzi scheme or not you
know
the bernie madoff told a lot of people
that if they give him their money he
will give them more in return
irrespective of what the stock market
will do now that was a beautiful idea
it appealed to a lot of people they gave
him their money what else can you expect
from people that believe
a beautiful idea you know they made
money and gave it to bernie madoff
because the idea was so beautiful
and he felt great about it they felt
great about it but when they wanted to
cash
out which was the experiment
he couldn't provide them the money
so this idea turned out to be wrong
and it's not just the nuance of science
to say
oh okay there is an experimental test
but you know we can give up on this
as long as we're happy and we feel very
smart
and we completely agree that we should
pursue these questions and just do
mathematical gymnastics and give each
other awards and feel great about
life and in general just make the
general statement that experiments would
be great but we can't do them right now
and therefore let's not even discuss
them having a culture of this type
is unhealthy for science because how can
you tell the difference
between the idea of bernie madoff and
reality
you can feel very happy until you try to
cash it out
and if you don't have an experimental
test during your life
then you might spend your life as a
physicist on an idea that
doesn't really describe reality and
that's
a risk that is a physicist i'm not
willing to take
i want to spend my life on ideas that i
can test
and if they are wrong i learn something
new
and by the way einstein was wrong three
times in the last decade of his career
he argued that black holes don't exist
gravitational waves don't exist
and quantum mechanics doesn't have
spooky action at the distance but that
was part of
his work at the frontiers of physics you
can be wrong
there's nothing bad about it when you
explore
new territories you don't always know if
you're heading in the right direction
as long as you're doing it with dignity
and honesty and integrity
and you are just following what is known
at a time it's part of the scientific
pursuit and that's why people should not
ridicule others that think outside the
box
as long as they are doing it honestly
and as long as the evidence
allows for what they are talking about
that should be considered seriously and
i think it's really important for the
health of the scientific endeavor
because
uh we're missing on opportunities to
discover new things
just to give an example in 1952 there
was an astronomer named
otto struve that they argued that we
might find planets
close in to a star like the sun if they
have the mass of jupiter because
if they're close in if they are hot
jupiters uh
heated by the sun getting very close to
the sun
then they would tag the sun like star
back and forth in a way that we can
measure or they would um
occult a significant portion of the area
of the star
so we can see them when they transit the
star so he argued let's search for those
and for four decades no not no time
on major facilities was allocated for
such research because astronomers
argued oh we pretty much understand why
jupiter formed so far away from the sun
and we shouldn't expect hot jupiters
and then in 1995 a hot jupiter was
discovered
and the nobel prize was given for that a
couple of years ago
so you might say okay that
baby was born eventually even though
four decades
were wasted uh eventually we found the
hot jupiter
and that opened up the field of
exoplanets but
my argument is that this is a baby that
was born
for each baby like that there must be
many babies that were never born
because it's still being argued that
it's not worth the effort to pursue
those
frontiers and that's unfortunate because
we are missing
opportunities to discover new things if
you are not
open to discover new things you will
never discover them
one thing that you mentioned earlier
that really caught my attention was you
were talking about us becoming
uh technologically advanced um and and
that that would unlock replicators and
that replicators could
uh you know explore the universe and
and um you know fundamentally change it
and
and life in our local galactic cluster
um you also that was also tied into
the search for the meaning for life and
a place where i see these two ideas as
intersecting is in the idea of the
cosmic endowment
so the cosmic endowment is this idea of
uh the total amount of matter and energy
that an intelligent species has
access to after it begins uh
creating replicators so since the
expansion of the universe is
accelerating
um there's some number of galaxies which
exist
outside of a volume that we have access
to
so there's a limited amount of energy
and matter that we can use
um for whatever the meaning of life is
whatever
good is so what do you think the
the cosmic endowment should be used for
right so i actually had an exchange with
freeman dyson on this question
when the accelerating universe was
discovered i wrote a paper saying
uh you know when the universe ages by a
factor of 10 we will be surrounded by
vacuum
beyond our galaxy and we will not have
contact with other civilizations with
resources and
he wrote back to me and said we should
engage in a cosmic engineering
project where we propel our star
and come together with other
civilizations and by that
we will not be left alone and i told him
look this cosmic engineering project is
very ambitious it's not practical
in fact there are locations where you
have much more resources a thousand
times more than in our milky way galaxy
these are called clusters of galaxies
and we can migrate
to the center of the nearest cluster of
galaxy
and and in fact
you know that there might be
a lot of journeys taken by advanced
civilizations towards
clusters of galaxies that would avoid
the cosmic expansion so that's my answer
of how to prepare for the cold winter
that awaits us
where we will be surrounded by back and
we it's best to go to the nearest
cluster of galaxy where the
amount of resources is a thousand times
larger
in addition to that
you can imagine that in the future we
will build the
accelerators that bring particles to
energies that
far exceed the large hadron collider and
the maximum particle energy that we can
imagine
is a so-called planck energy scale and
if you imagine developing our
accelerator techniques
you can in principle uh imagine building
an accelerator
within the solar system that will reach
plank energies
and if you collide particles at these
energies
you know we don't really know the
physics of quantum gravity but you can
imagine
a situation where you would irritate the
vacuum to a level where
the vacuum will start burning up because
we know the vacuum has some
mass density some energy density that is
causing the accelerated expansions the
so-called cosmological constant and if
you bring the vacuum to a zero energy
density state
then you have an excess energy that is
just like a burning front it's the
energy you get from a propellant that
burns
and you get a domain wall that can
expand
and consume all the vacuum energy
along its path and of course it moves at
the speed of light
so if you were to be on the path of such
a domain ward
you would not get an advanced warning
and
it will burn up everything along its
path
at the speed of light so i think if we
ever meet
advanced civilizations that have the
capabilities
of building accelerators that reach the
planck scale
we should sign a treaty a galactic
treaty
whereby we will never collide particles
approaching that energy in order not to
risk
everyone else from domain walls that
would burn them up
and that's just a matter of cosmic
responsibility
i i think max tegmark calls these uh
death bubbles
yeah i mean these are domain walls that
of course we
we have no evidence for but could be
triggered by collisions at the planck
scale and
a matter of cosmic responsibility is not
to generate these domain wars
artificially
let's pivot into looking for life and
and space archaeology
which is a cool term that you've created
and looking for them through bio
signatures and techno signatures
uh one place that i'm curious to to
start here is
um since we were just talking about
replicators
why is it that we don't find evidence of
replicators or large-scale
superstructures in other galaxies
or in our own galaxy for example like a
galaxy
where half of it has been turned into
dyson spheres
and so you know it's like half
illuminated
right i mean presumably such things do
not exist
uh it's actually very difficult to
imagine
an engineering project that will
construct a dyson sphere and
i think it's much more prudent for an
advanced civilization to
to build the small pieces of equipment
that go through the vast space in
between stars
and that is actually very difficult for
us to detect with existing
instrumentation you know
even a spacecraft as big as a football
field
would be noticed only when it passes
within the earth's orbit around the sun
that's the only region where pan stars
detected
objects the size of umuah
from the reflected sunlight so
we will not notice such objects when
they are farther
than the earth is from the sun and
you know the distance to the nearest
star is hundreds of
thousands of times bigger than that so
most of space
is not uh it could be
filled with things passing through it
and is that are not visible to us
uh you know a spacecraft the size of a
football field is huge
we cannot imagine something much bigger
than that
um and so i would argue that there could
be a lot of things floating through
space
also you know as of now our telescopes
were not monitoring
uh for objects that move very fast you
know a fraction of the speed of light
obviously you know if astronomers saw
something moving across the sky
so fast they would dismiss it they would
say it makes no sense
you know we are looking for asteroids or
comets that are moving
at the a percent of a percent of the
speed of light 10 to the minus four of
the speed of light so
um so part of it is our inability to
consider possibilities that may exist
out there but most of
the fact that we haven't yet detected a
lot of these objects
is a lack of sensitivity you know we
can't really
see these things when they're far away
unless there are major mega structures
as you pointed out but
i think such engineering projects are
unlikely
so i i i'm curious why you feel the
engineering projects like that
are unlikely like it seems like the
some of the one of the most interesting
things you can do is computation
computation seems like it has something
to do with with creating consciousness
and consciousness
seems like it is the bedrock of of value
given that
that all value arises in conscious
experience
so like i would imagine the
you know using the energy of suns to
enable vast amounts of computation is
one of the most interesting things that
a civilization
can do and the objects that they might
send out to
other solar systems would be at like a
nanoscale
right you send out like nanoscale
replicators um so they would be even
smaller than
than football fields or smaller than
umua and then those would
begin i don't know dyson sphere
engineering projects right
and so with artificial superintelligence
and billions and billions of years
to go in the universe uh in some sense
it feels like we're in the early
universe
um it feels curious to me why why
superstructures would would be unlikely
i'm not sure right
you know if you think about what a star
is
a star is just a nuclear reactor that is
bound by gravity
okay and that doesn't seem to be like
the optimal
system for us to use uh it's better to
build
an artificial nuclear reactor that is
not bound by gravity like
a nuclear engine nuclear reactor we're
trying to do that it's not easy to build
the
effusion reactor on earth but we do have
efficient reactor and
if i were to think about using nuclear
energy i would say
it's much better to use artificially
made
nuclear engines than to use
uh the energy produced by a giant
nuclear reactor that nature
produced in particular locations because
then
you can carry your engine with you you
are always
close to it you can harness all of its
energy
and you don't need to put a huge
structure
around the star which you know brings in
a lot of
engineering difficulties or challenges
so i would be leaning in the direction
of
having small systems a lot of small
systems
uh you know sent out rather than
a giant system that covers a star
but once again i would argue that you
know we should look at the evidence and
there are constraints on uh dyson
spheres that
imply that they're not very common um i
should say a couple of weeks ago i wrote
this
a paper and with an undergraduate
student in stanford
the uh eliza
tabor that considers
the possibility of detecting artificial
lights on the night side of proxima b
the
the habitable planet around the nearest
star proxima centauri
using the james webb space telescope and
we
showed that then one can put very
interesting limits
on the level of artificial illumination
on the dark side
of that planet if there are any city
lights out there
and the other technological signatures
that one can look for
are for example industrial pollution in
the atmosphere of planet i wrote a paper
about that
six years ago you can look for
reflectance that indicates uh
photovoltaic
cells on the day side of a planet
uh which is quite different than the
reflectance of rock
it has a spectral edge you can look for
light beams that sweep across the sky
that you see them as a flash of light
for example the light
beam used for propulsion using light
sails you know if you imagine
another planetary system where cargoes
are being delivered from an earth-like
planet to a mars-like planet
using light sails uh the beam of light
could cross our line of sight and we
could
see it as a flash of light and we can
have even correlate it with the two
planets passing
uh along our line of sight and so that
would give us confidence that indeed
it's a light sail
traveling between those two planets that
we are witnessing
so there are all kind and i wrote a
paper about that in 2016.
so there are all kinds of technological
signatures we can search for
but we need to search for it and we need
to put funds towards this search
right so we have both bio signatures and
techno signatures
in terms of biosignatures there is
looking you've proposed looking in the
clouds of brown dwarfs and green dwarfs
there's looking around our own solar
system
through um looking at the elements in
um for example the atmosphere of venus
there was phosphine which we
thought could not exist except through
biological pathways and so
uh it was it's hypothesized that maybe
there's some kind of life in the
atmosphere of
venus um they're searching for other
chemicals they're
searching other planets for elements
that can't exist without life
and then in terms of techno signatures
right they're searching for radio waves
which you've talked about
seti um seti's primary
uh way of looking for life but it but it
potentially needing a refresh
where it is for example looking for
artificial light or the remnants of
industry um and you've also proposed the
uh increasing the threshold of
sensitivities
for developing um image imaging that is
that is increasingly sensitive right
because was it basically
was it at the limit of um you know our
telescope's capacity
it was roughly i mean it was at the
level of
sensitivity that allows us definite
detection but
we can't see objects that are much
smaller than that or much
reflect much less light than omaha did
yeah so i should say that all of these
both biological signatures and
technological signatures
are being reviewed in a in a new
textbook that
i wrote together with my former postdoc
manasvi lingam
that is coming out to be published on
the 29th
of june 2021 um
it's more than a thousand times a
thousand pages long
it's a 1061 pages long
and it has an overview of
the current scientific knowledge we have
and expectations we have
for biological signatures and
technological signatures
the title of the book is life in the
cosmos
and it's to be published by harvard
university press
it is meant to be a textbook for
scientific research
as a follow-up on my popular level book
exo terrestrial right if you just put in
the course
live in the cosmos harvard university
press you'll get to the
webpage it's also on amazon already for
sale because it's
it will come out in two weeks
so pivoting a bit here do you feel that
i know we mentioned this a little bit
earlier
and when we were talking about the
difference between aliens being
interested in us or
compelled to reach out to us because of
ethical concerns
did you think that advanced alien
civilizations can
converge on ethics and beneficence
and that's an interesting question um it
really depends on
on their value system and it also
depends on darwinian selection the
question is
what kind of civilizations will be most
abundant if you look at human history
very often
the more aggressive less ethical
cultures
survive because they were able to
destroy the others
so it's not just a matter of which
values
appear to be more noble it's the
question of
which set of values leads to
survival in the long run and domination
in the long run
and then without knowing the full
spectrum of possibilities we we can't
really assess that
so once again i would say the smart
thing for us to do
is be careful i mean not transmit too
much
to the outside world until we figure out
if we have neighbors you know there was
this joke
when i love lucy was
replayed again and again that
we might get a message uh from another
planet saying
if you keep replaying reruns of i love
lucy we will invade you
um so we i think it's
well it's it's important for us to be
careful and figure out first whether
you know there are smarter kids on the
block
uh but having said that if we ever
establish contact or if you find
equipment
in our neighborhood uh the question is
what to do
how it's a policy question how to
respond to that
and then it really depends on the nature
of what we find
you know how much more advanced is
the equipment that we uncover uh
what were the intentions of those who
produced it and sent it these are
fundamental questions that will guide
our policy
and our behavior and until we find
conclusive evidence
uh you know we should wait uh until
until that moment so to push back a
little bit on the darwinian
um argument right that's of course a
factor where we have this kind of game
theoretic expression of genes
the selfish gene trying to propagate
itself through generations and that
leading to behaviors
and and you know how the human being is
conditioned by
evolution in that way there's also the
sense that over time humanity has become
increasingly
moral um we're of course doing plenty of
things right now that are wrong but
um morality seems to be improving over
time
and so this leads to a question where um
for example do you think that there is a
relationship
a necessary relationship between what is
true and what is good
so for example if if an intelligent
species
you need to know more and more true
facts in order to for example
spread throughout the universe and so if
there's a necessary relationship between
what is true and what is good then you
would
there would be a convergence then also
on what is good as
as truth continues to to progress yeah
i was asked in a forum
when i joked about the fact that i'm
seeking intelligence in space in the sky
because i don't find it often here on
earth
a member of the audience chuckled and
they asked me
how do you define an intelligent
civilization
and the way i define it is by the
guiding principles
of science which is
sharing or cooperation
on evidence-based knowledge
okay and the word cooperation
is extremely important i believe that
intelligence is marked by cooperation
not by fighting each other because
that's
a sink for our energy for our resources
that doesn't do any good so promoting a
better future for ourselves through
cooperation
is a trademark of intelligence
it's also the guiding principle of
science
uh the second component of this
of these guiding principles is uh
evidence-based
knowledge and the way i view
science is as an infinite sum game
you know in economics you have a
zero-sum game where if someone
makes a profit another person loses in
science when we
increase the level of knowledge we have
everyone benefits when a vaccine was
developed
for covet 19 everyone on earth benefited
from it
and so science aims to increase
the territory of this island of
knowledge that we have in the ocean of
ignorance that surrounds it and
uh it should be evidence-based not based
on our prejudice
so that's what i hope the future of
humanity is
it will be coincident with the guiding
principles
of science meaning people will cooperate
with each other
nations will cooperate with each other
and try to share evidence-based
knowledge rather than what's the
alternative the alternative is what we
are doing right now
uh fighting each other trying to feel
superior relative to each other
if you look at human history you know
the
uh you find racism you find the
attempts to fill uh supremacy or
uh elitism or uh
you know all kinds of uh
phenomena that stem from um a desire to
feel superior relative to other people
and that's ridiculous in the big scheme
of things because
you know we are such an unimportant
player in the cosmic stage
that we should all feel modest not try
to feel superior relative to each other
because any
advantage that we have relative to each
other is really minuscule
in the big scheme of things you know the
color of the skin is completely
meaningless
who cares what the color of the skin is
like
what significance could that have for
the qualities of a person
and yet a lot of human history
is shaped around that or you know and
then
this is not the intelligent way for us
to behave as a species
uh we should focus on the guiding
principles
of science which are cooperation
and sharing of evidence-based knowledge
rather than ridiculing each other
rather than uh trying to feel superior
relative to each other right
rather than fighting each other let's
work together towards
a better future and demonstrate that we
are intelligent
so that we will acquire a place in the
club of intelligent species in the milky
way galaxy
do you see morality as evidence-based
knowledge
i think morality you know if you listen
to [ __ ]
it's the logical thing to do
[Music]
if you uh consider a principle such that
you know it will promote the better good
of of everyone
around you you're basically taking into
consideration
others and shaping your behavior so that
if
other people follow the same principles
uh we will be in a better world okay and
uh that to me is a sign of uh
recognizing evidence because the
evidence is that you don't live alone if
you are to live alone
if you are the only person on earth
morality loses significance
not only that it there is nobody else
for you to consider morality relative to
that's not the issue the issue is that
it's irrelevant you don't need to
consider morality because you're the
only person so
you don't even you can do whatever you
want you know like
it has no effect on other people
therefore morality is not not relevant
you can do whatever you want but given
the fact
that you look at the evidence and you
realize that you're not alone
that's evidence you shape your behavior
based on that evidence
and i do think that's evidence-based
knowledge
definitely how do you see axiomatic
based knowledge so for example
um base like axioms of morality and
mathematics
that build these these structures
they're also axioms for example of
science like this value of communication
and evidence-based
reasoning and and axioms and morality
are for example
might be that um i don't know like
consciousness is
like value and dis value are innate and
intrinsically experienced in
consciousness
um and then there are axioms in in
mathematics which which
um you know motivate and structure that
field so
um how do you so
you know we've talked a lot about
science and evidence-based reasoning but
but what about knowledge the the you
know in the philosophical territory
which
is almost um uh like a priori true like
like things which we we rest fields upon
how do you see that yeah i
i i do believe that there is room for
humanities of the
future you know the the way that
philosophy was handled
in past centuries should be updated
and let me illustrate that with an
example related to your question
basically suppose we want to decide
about the principles of morality
the way to do that is you can construct
a simulation that includes a lot of
people
so in principle if you include all the
ingredients that
make people behave one way or another
you know it doesn't need to be rational
reasoning you can include this
some randomness or some other elements
that shape human behavior based on their
environment you can include that in the
simulation
so let's just imagine a simulation where
you put individual people
and the way you put you have an
algorithm for the way that they
respond to their environment doesn't
need to be by rational reasoning it
could be emotional it could be any other
way that you find appropriate and you
put that
you have the building blocks each of
them is a person and you introduce the
randomness that is in the population
and then you run the simulation and you
see what happens
okay so this is just like trying to
produce human history artificially
and then you introduce principles for
the
behavior of people guiding principles
just like moral principles so first you
let people behave in a completely crazy
way like
anything they want and you will get
chaos
as the outcome of this simulation
but if you introduce principles of
morality
you can see the outcomes that will come
out of it
uh so what i would say is
in principle you know in the future if
we have a sophisticated enough
computer algorithm to describe behavior
of people based on our
understanding of how people behave you
know if we
get a better sense of how people behave
and respond to their environment
we can design the optimal code by which
people should behave such that we will
end up
in a stable society that is intelligent
that
follows the kind of principles i
mentioned before that is older
orderly and that benefits everyone for a
better future and
you know that's one way of approaching
it and obviously in the past
philosophers could not approach it this
way because they didn't have the
computer uh capabilities that we
currently have
um you know you can imagine artificial
intelligence
addressing this task in principle
right so you can you can set moral
principles and moral parameters for a
system and then evolve the system right
but the there's criteria for evaluating
the success or not of that system and
those
are more like moral axioms so as as a
scientist i'm curious about how you
approach
uh for example moral axioms that you use
for evaluating the evolution of a
particular moral system
so my uh criterion the one that i think
you know that that guides me is
maintaining the longevity
of the human species so whatever
will keep us for the longest amount of
time
you know of course bearing in mind that
the physical conditions will change on
earth so within a billion years the
sun will boil off all the oceans on
earth but
but let's leave that aside you know
let's just ask suppose you put the
people in a box and
and and and let them you know generation
after generation
and let them follow some principles what
would be the ideal principles to
maintain
the stability of society and the
longevity
of the human species that's that's what
will guide me
okay uh uh i think uh
survival is really the key for
maintaining your ideas that's the
precondition right so
in nature things that are transient they
go away they don't survive and they lose
their value
so they have less value i mean obviously
in the short term they could have more
value but
i care about the long term and i define
the principles based on how long they
would allow us to
survive would you add expected value to
that calculation so
it's not just time but it's actually
like the expected
reward or expected value over time right
because some futures are worse than
others and so maybe we wouldn't want to
just have longevity
uh yeah there is the issue of being
happy
and pleased with
the environment that you live in and
that could be
factored in but i think the primary
principle would be
uh survival because within any
population you always will
will find a fraction of of the
components that are
happy and it partly depends on on
the circumstances that they live in but
partly on the way they accept those
circumstances you know
you can live in the barrel and be happy
uh
you can be in a mansion and be unhappy
so it's complicated as to what makes you
happy and
um um i would put that as a secondary
condition
i would more i would worry more about
social structures that maintain
longevity on humanity's longevity we're
we're basically beginning to become
technologically advanced we're facing
existential risks in the 21st century
from
artificial intelligence and nuclear
weapons in synthetic
biology um and there's
there's ufos and there's moammoa and
a lot of really interesting crazy things
are going on so i i'm curious if you
could touch on the
the challenge of humanity's response and
the need for international governance
for potentially
communicating and encountering alien
life well i do think it's extremely
important for us
to recognize that we belong to the same
species so
all the confrontations we often have in
politics
between nations um they should
play a lesser role in
guiding our behavior uh cooperation on
on the global scale international
cooperation is extremely important
and let me give an example from recent
history
there was a virus that came from wuhan
china
and if the scientists were allowed to
gather
all the information of
how this virus came and what the
characteristics of this virus
are then the vaccine would have been
developed earlier and it could have
saved the lives of many people so
i would say in the global world that we
live in today
our problem many of our problems are
global and therefore
we should cooperate on the solutions and
that argues
against you know putting borders
in our knowledge trying again to gain
superiority of one nation relative to
another but
instead help each other and
towards a better future and you know
it's really the science that provides
the international
the glue that that can bind us
internationally and i i realize you know
i'm
trying to be realist that it may not
happen every
anytime soon that people recognize the
value of science as the
international glue but i hope that
eventually we will
realize that this is the only path that
will bring
us to survival to a better future
if we act based on cooperation
on evidence-based knowledge in 2020 you
have an
article where you advocate for creating
an elite scientific body to advise
uh on global catastrophes as
the future of life institute we're
interested in reducing the risks of
existential risks so ways in which
technology can be misused or
um you know lead to accidents which lead
to the extinction
of of life on earth could you comment on
your perspective
on the need for an elite scientific body
to advise on
existential risk and global catastrophic
risk
well we noticed that during the pandemic
we were not we were not really prepared
especially in the western world
because the last big
major pandemic of this of this magnitude
took place a century ago and
nobody around today in politics or
otherwise
was around back then and as a result we
were not ready we were not
prepared and i think it's prudent
to have an organization that will
cultivate cooperation
globally uh and you know it could be
established by the united nations it
could be
a different body but um once again it's
important for us to plane
plan ahead and avoid
catastrophes that could be more damaging
than kovite 19
and if you prevent them it would
more than overpay for the investment of
funds
uh just to give you another example uh
uh
solar eruptions solar storms um
you know if there was a current on event
uh
about a hundred and fifty years ago uh
it was a big eruption on the sun
uh that brought energetic particles to
earth and
back in the mid the 19th century
there wasn't much technological
infrastructure but if the same event
would have happened today
it would cost trillions of dollars to
the world economy because it would
damage
power grids and uh satellites
and communication and so forth and
it would be extremely expensive so it's
important for us to plan ahead
there was a about seven years ago there
was
a a plume of hot gas that was ejected by
the sun and it just missed
the earth and uh we should be ready for
that and
and the build infrastructure that would
protect us for such a catastrophe
and there are many more so one can go
through the risks and some of them are
bigger than others some of them are
rarer than others uh of course one of
them is
the risk from an asteroid hitting the
earth and the
congress tasked nasa to find all
asteroids uh all rocks bigger than the
size of
about 140 meters they wanted the
nasa to find the 90 of all of those that
would could potentially intercept the
earth and and collide with earth uh
and then the pan stars telescope that
we started from that discovered was
funded for finding such near-earth
objects
and the the vera rubin observatory will
most likely
fulfill two-thirds of the congressional
task and find sixty percent of
of all the near-earth asteroids bigger
than
140 meters um and then
you know that shows that the human brain
is actually much more useful for
survival
than the body of a dinosaur because the
dinosaurs had huge bodies
and 66 million years ago you know they
were very proud of themselves they
dominated their environment they ate
grass and were happy
uh and then from the sky came this giant
rock the size of
manhattan island and when it hit the
ground it tarnished
their ego trip uh abruptly and
uh so just to show you that the human
brain even though it's much smaller
than the dinosaur body is much more
precious
for protecting us because we can design
telescopes that would alert us
to incoming objects and that's a
catastrophe that
obviously we can protect ourselves
against by
shifting the trajectories of objects
heading our way as a final question
i'm curious what are the most
fundamental questions to you
in life and what what motivates and and
excites you from
moment to moment as you know a human
being on earth
i've i've read or heard that you're
you're really interested in
existentialism
uh as a kid um so yeah what are the most
foundational or important questions to
you well the fundamental
uh issue is that we live for a finite
time with short time you know and
um and so the question
is what's the meaning of our existence
you see because
very often we forget that this
trip that is very exciting that we are
having
and could be very stimulating and
intriguing
is finite and you know when i realized
that when both my parents passed away
over the past three years
um i came to the realization that
you know i don't give a damn of on what
other people think i you know let's
focus on the substance let's keep our
eyes on the ball not on the audience
and then it was the focusing of
of my attention to the important things
in life um that we should appreciate
uh and then there is this fundamental
question of
why is life worth living what are we
living life
for and what is the meaning of our life
and you know that's it may well be that
there is no meaning that we just
go through this interesting trip we are
spectators of the universe
and we should enjoy the the play
while it lasts uh but that again argues
that
we should be modest and and behave like
spectators rather than
you know trying to shape our immediate
environment and feel
a sense of deep arrogance as a result of
that
that was the view of the dinosaurs
before the rock hit
hit them so in a way
you know what gives me a sense of
meaning for life is just looking at the
universe and learning from it you know
that
i don't really care about my colleagues
you know every morning i
jog at 5 00 a.m i develop this routine
during the pandemic and i enjoy the
company of
birds ducks wild turkeys and rabbits
and i really enjoy nature left
to its own much more than than people
because
there is something true you know
in looking at me every morning i see
something different i see a
today i saw a red bird
i saw the sunrise was completely
different than yesterday
uh so every day you can learn new things
and you just need to pay attention
not to feel that you know everything
it's not about
us it's about what is going on around us
that we should pay attention to and you
know once we behave more like
kids appreciating things around us and
learning from them
then we would feel happier and you know
i was asked by the harvard gazette what
is the one thing i would like to change
about the world and i said i would like
my colleagues to behave more like kids
uh basically not being driven by
promoting their image
but rather you know willing to make
mistakes putting
skin in the game and learning regarding
life as a learning experience
we might be wrong sometimes but we are
doing our best
to figure out when we are wrong all
right avi thank you very much for
for inspiring this this childlike
curiosity in science
for also helping to improve the
you know the cultural and epistemic
situation in science and also for
for your work on a moammoa and
everything to do with extraterrestrials
and astronomy
so thank you very much for coming on the
podcast thanks for having me i had a
great time